hi
welcome to our session serverless
functions fast that is secure
scalable resilient anywhere
my name is vinod and i'm a product
manager at google and i'm presenting
with my colleague dustin ingram
and matthew lawson from ikea so let's
get started
so here's today's agenda first we'll
give you an overview of the product
cloud functions
then we'll walk you through key function
as a service use cases
then we'll follow up with an interesting
case study from ikea and their digital
transformation with serverless
after that we'll walk you through key
security capabilities and diagnosability
and availability capabilities in
serverless at google cloud
and then walk you through our functions
everywhere vision so let's get started
cloud functions cloud functions is
google's event driven serverless compute
platform
where users can write small snippets of
code that react to events
as well as http you can write up these
functions very easily
and get started to process you know
small snippets of code for say for
example uploading a file to google cloud
storage and do some processing
also wrap up with some ml apis do some
ml processing on the file
and then store the results back in the
cloud cloud functions is truly
serverless
where you pay only for what you use it
scales seamlessly
with zero infrastructure management it
also has a streamlined development model
where you wrap up and write a function
very quickly
in addition it's integrated with key
events all across gcp
to build up complicated applications and
services
when we talk to users users really like
to use cloud functions
for its simplicity scalability the fact
that you don't have to manage servers
the pay for use model and the fact that
it's connected with broad range of cloud
services
key functions of the service use cases
that our customers use cloud functions
are
are things like serverless web hooks
where users can wide up
you know functions with github
notifications that are processed
and then served in slack further
real-time data processing
wherein users can you know upload data
to the cloud to cloud storage
uh you know trigger a function to do
some processing
uh call an ml api and then store the
results in the cloud again
serverless iot backends where you know
users have iot systems all across the
world sending things like sensor and
temperature data
and then that's processed through pub
sub messaging systems that trigger cloud
functions
and then you do some iot analytics and
then store the results in the cloud
and then uh intelligent applications
using ai and bigquery for example
you know chatbots using twilio where
functions are wired up
to invoke an ml api or a natural
language processing api
as well as doing sentiment analysis with
that and trend analysis with bigquery
along with these key fast use cases when
we talk to customers
they have several key fast user needs
that come up
and these needs are things like
developer productivity
building complex enterprise workflows
with serverless and functions
building applications that are secure
and then having the ability to build
applications
with multiple languages with
diagnosability debugging capabilities
telemetry and local development
further users will care about global
availability and scalability
to ensure their application and
functions scale for their application
traffic
in addition users really care about
portability and can we reduce vendor
lock-in when we build our serverless
applications
and to meet these user needs cloud
functions offers the following key
differentiators
first is ease of use cloud functions is
a very easy to use
product where users can write up a
function very quickly from the ui
from the cli from their favorite ide
and from an api for example
here's a simple function in node.js
where users just written hello cloud
next the user quickly wires it up and
deploys it using
the cli and then it's ready serving
traffic
all in a single command the user is
writing their code
you know it's getting built in the cloud
it's getting deployed in the cloud with
head checks
and then is within minutes running and
ready to serve traffic
this is really powerful that all in a
single command a user can get this
and achieve so much along with the ease
of use
cloud functions offers the ability to
build complex end-to-end solutions
these end-to-end solutions can be built
using key powerful building blocks which
are event-based
for things like data processing with ml
apis and bigquery and so on
and then for automation workloads with
things such as cloud scheduler cloud
tasks and so on and so forth
and to walk you through this application
journey of building end-to-end
applications
i would like to now invite matthew
larson from ikea
to walk you through ikea's digital
transformation with serverless and cloud
functions
hello and good morning good afternoon or
good evening depending on what time it
is wherever you're watching this
i'm very happy to do this presentation
for you today but of course i would love
to have done this in person
but because of the current global
situation i get to do this from my home
office here in sweden
so in this talk i'm going to explain to
you how ikea is using google cloud
functions
and other serverless technologies in our
engineering efforts
as we go through a digital
transformation
so my name is matthew lawson and i work
at ikea as an engineering manager here
in southern sweden
i usually don't start my presentations
off with who ikea is
but i do have a couple company slides
two of them to be exact
so first maybe i can share something
that you might not know about ikea
and that is our vision it has very
little to do with furniture
actually has nothing to do with
furniture and that is to create a better
everyday life for the many people
so whether it's becoming one of the
world's leaders in sustainability
starting to sell solar panels working
with international charities
or creating that great furniture for the
home all of this to help the many people
to create that better everyday life but
the two words out of that vision that
mean the most to me are
many people and to let you know what i
mean let me give you some numbers here
so ikea is over 76 years old and is made
up of many companies
organizations and hundreds of thousands
of co-workers across the globe
so here are some highlights from our
previous fiscal year as of september 1st
2019.
so ikea had 433 stores open
with 12 of them opening that fiscal year
and actually within the last few months
of this
recording we have over 450 now we have
211 000 co-workers working for us
globally
and this is growing especially in our
digital organizations across the globe
and we're now opening small stores in
city centers as an example of this
within the first four months of opening
we had a million visitors
to our ikea mandalay store in downtown
paris
we have billions of visitors to our
website each year and we have
over 100 million ikea family or our
loyalty program
across the globe as well so this means
that when we
when we create a new physical product or
a new digital product like a mobile app
web application or an api we need to
make sure we cater to those many people
the millions of people
so ikea as in many different companies
are going through a
digital transformation ikea has been
around since 1958
and to be completely transparent we have
quite a bit of technical debt across the
organization
or what we like to call it as our
spaghetti in the data center
our digital transformation was not
simply a matter of migrating to the
cloud
one decision we made early on was how
this was going to happen
we did not want to do a complete lift
and shift to a cloud partner but instead
we decided to re-engineer the
organization and digital products at the
same time
our chief operations manager stated once
we are flying a plane and changing the
engine at the same time
personally to me this is quite hard to
do but as an engineer it has been a ton
of fun
so new solutions and projects are
striving to be completely cloud native
and this is quite hard to do when the
brain of your application the data
is still sitting on premise and we're
doing a lot of work in that area
internally as well
creating new data pipelines to cater
both the old and the new
so one of the use cases that we started
re-engineering that is heavily using
google cloud functions and many other
serverless technologies
is our almost live feed of our inventory
system that we have at each ikea
location across the globe
so this enables us to show a live feed
of what is selling allowing us to export
that data to bigquery for further
analysis
or and also to create dashboards to give
the store insights on what is happening
instead of that daily or weekly report
and i'm sure there's much more use cases
that we haven't even thought up of yet
here so let's take a look at
architecture of one of the use cases
that my
fellow co-worker michael created first
we have our inventory server which sits
on premise
at each ikea location and talks the
google cloud
through a compute engine from a shared
vpc on a vpn
vpn and this sends many different
messages as xml
the xml is then compared to google cloud
storage looking for new or changed rows
and the ones that are changed are sent
as a json object to
a pub subtopic we then have a batch
receiving side of this
which uses google cloud functions and
actually powers this entire architecture
this pulls in messages from pub sub and
puts the raw data into many different
bigquery data sets depending on the
message type and we can also move that
message on for further processing using
other pop-up topics
finally we're pulling in the messages
from the capturing google cloud function
using a schedule system
as well that was built and this is using
cloud scheduler
another google cloud function cloud
tasks and this
configuration data is stored in
firestore so this tells the
google cloud function the capturing one
how often to execute
depending on some criteria like the
amount of messages in the queue
time and also optimizes everything from
a cost per
perspective as well we then can create
custom dashboards using the bigquery
data sets
and all we can also process it further
on like i said with pops up topics
one aspect of this architecture that
we're currently working on is the
ingestion of data
from the on-premise server to the cloud
we're looking at how we can do this
without using a vpn tunnel or shared vpc
so some people have asked me why are we
using google cloud functions here and
not something like dataflow
well one thing we like to say here at
ikea is we do not respect the solution
until we know what it costs
and if this solution was to be turned
into mission critical then we could
change the architecture to better
support message ordering duplication
and other aspects this solution
currently handles between 60
and for to 60 000 messages per a minute
and can certainly scale higher higher as
we've seen
and it actually costs around 30 us
dollars per month to operate to get the
the data from our on-premise to google
cloud functions
and so this really showcases the power
of serverless without
needing to spend a ton of money so let's
take a quick look at a demo that my
colleagues axel and joel created
to show what you can kind of do with
this data so here is a map of north
america
with our stores and for fun we're just
showing our inventory changes from
our iconic product the fracta blue bag
so as you can see here we're getting
some messages popping in from
sales that are happening in those stores
and this really kind of showcases how
you can use serverless technology to
bridge between what you're doing on
premise
to new cloud technologies
so with that if you have any other
further questions you can please feel
free to contact me my email address is
here
and also as i mentioned we're also
hiring so please visit
join.inca.com for more information
around that and with that i thank you
for listening
and please stay safe out there thank you
matthew for that amazing presentation on
ikea's digital transformation with
serverless and cloud functions
now moving on one of the key user needs
as well as security and
cloud functions offers key security
differentiators
for users and serverless one of the key
features we offer is per function
identities
where we provide fine grained control on
which users
are privileged to invoke a function and
we take it a step further
and also provide on which specific
resources a function has access to
for example here's a user who's trying
to invoke a cloud function using cloud
scheduler
and you know that user is authorized and
the user can invoke the function
and then there's a malicious user who's
trying to invoke the same function
and is prevented to do so likewise
here's a cloud function that has
permissions to access bigquery but it
does not have permissions to access
cloud storage
by providing these fine grain controls
on security
you know we really help users control
who can access the function and which
resources a function can access
and then take the security level a step
further
along with that users really care about
vpc
they have systems across the cloud as
well as on-prem in vpc networks
and our cloud functions play really nice
with these vpc networks
functions can connect with these vps
networks and we take it a step further
uh by providing what is called vpc sc or
a security parameter
to prevent things like data exfiltration
along with you know fine grain access
and vpc
users are really concerned about the
denial of wallet attack and serverless
for instance if you know a user service
gets a lot of requests from a malicious
user
they could at the end of the month get a
shocking bill if their you know
scaling is not capped to prevent this we
offer a service called
max instances that let users cap their
you know serverless services thereby you
know preventing
you know the denial of wallet attack and
also letting their serverless service
scale to the extent as needed
and within their monthly budgets along
with scalability and security users
really care about
you know multiple languages
diagnosability and local development
cloud functions today is available in
key languages such as python node and go
further we're super excited to announce
java 11 which is generally available
as well as dart net and ruby and we have
more runtimes coming soon as well
and to talk to you more about
diagnosability and fall tolerance
i would like to now invite dustin on
stage to give you a demo in the space
hi i'm dustin ingram developer advocate
for google cloud
let's take a look at how we can build a
reliable resilient
self-healing system using cloud
functions and cloud pub sub
let's say we've got a fleet of deployed
iot sensors that are sending temperature
data
in degrees fahrenheit along with a
sensor id and json payload via an http
post
to a cloud function now say we want to
take that temperature data
and write it to firestore which is our
operational database
and also write it to bigquery which is
our data analytics warehouse
traditionally we would probably do this
in the same application
or in the same function but this has a
couple drawbacks
so if for example the code that writes
to bigquery is not available
or has a bug in it or maybe there's a
networking glitch
and it can't talk to the service now the
function errors out and you're left in a
weird state should i rerun the function
but then what if firestore write did
succeed and now i've written to
firestore twice
what is the overall state of my
application
so we want to decouple these now one way
we could do this
is to put it into two cloud functions
one that writes to firestore
and one that writes to bigquery and this
is a step in the right direction
but that post temperature function is
still responsible for running and
retrying
and understanding if those other
functions succeeded or failed
so we want to decouple these completely
and to do that we'll use
cloud pub sub which is a high scale
messaging bus
on google cloud now all post temperature
has to do
is write a message to the pub sub bus
and then it's done
the write bigquery and write firestore
functions are listening for messages
coming in on that topic in cloudpub sub
when they get those messages they'll do
their functionality
and they'll fail and retry independently
from each other
asynchronously let's take a look at this
in action
here are the three cloud functions that
we talked about
post temperature write bigquery and
write firestore
i've written a shell script to simulate
the iot sensor posting their data via an
http post
so they're going to post it to this
sensors collection in firestore
and you can see these values coming in
but we've also got a tracking sheet
that we wrote that this actually looks
at the timestamps coming in
and puts in a message when it's about to
try writing to bigquery
about to try writing to firestore and
then whether it's succeeded or failed
and you can see these update in real
time
everything is good so it's all
successful but i want to simulate an
error in the let's say write bigquery
function
so i'm going to open up the editor here
in cloud functions
there's a built-in editor but you can
also use your normal ide
your normal editor to deploy from your
workstation and so on
but this is handy for doing quick edits
so i'm going to go here and i'm going to
intentionally break this function
i'm going to change the name of the
table from readings to let's just say
readings with a few s's so maybe one of
our
python developers made a typo and put
the wrong name of the table
so let's deploy this so i'm deploying a
broken version of the write bigquery
function
and while that's deploying you can look
at some of the other attributes of our
cloud function
you can set identity so your function
can maybe only access certain resources
or you can set environment variables for
example the sheet id that we're doing
the updating in
all right so now that our function is
deployed i'm going to rerun that shell
script that simulates
10 iot sensor readings coming in and
let's go look at it in google sheets
so you can see it's succeeding and
trying and you can see it's happening
asynchronously
those functions are running and failing
independently we've set cloud functions
to retry which means that if it gets an
error
it will retry immediately if it gets
another error again
it'll wait a bit longer and so on and so
forth as an exponential back off
all right so those are all failed so we
want to figure out okay
what went wrong now i know what went
wrong because i put that typo in there
but let's pretend that we didn't and we
actually need to debug this
cloud logging automatically picks up all
the logging messages from cloud
functions
but also cloud run app engine kubernetes
and a bunch of others
and you can see we can identify our
error here the table cloud funcs
readings
is not available so cloud logging is
great
you can do monitoring and alerting you
can have it automatically aggregate
error reports
using error reporting and it's really
handy and useful tool
for debugging your serverless code on
google cloud
so let's fix our bigquery function i'm
going to load the editor back
up and fix it so that instead of
readings with many s's
it's just readings with one s and then
we will redeploy this
now let's check our tracking sheet where
you can see it's actually been
retrying this whole time as it retries
again with the new version of write
bigquery
it'll start to succeed now instead of
failing and again
all we did was redeploy the function we
had to set cloud functions to retry so
the data wouldn't be lost
because the system is keeping track of
it internally as it retries the function
with the same payload again
and again until it succeeds and that'll
happen for up to seven days
retrying your cloud function so you
don't have to worry about losing data
and that is how you can build a reliable
resilient
self-healing system with cloud functions
thank you dustin for the amazing demo on
diagnosability
and fault tolerance now moving on
uh when users are using servers and
cloud functions
they really care about uh local
development and disconnected development
imagine that you're working in your team
and you have to take a flight
or seven hour flight uh you know and you
want to continue developing your
application
that you're working with on your team
you can now do that with cloud functions
uh as well as on your plane and then
when you land you can you know connect
with your team
and share your work as well to do this
you know let's unpack what's really in
your function a function
is as running in an operating system for
a particular runtime such as node.js
with a web framework for that particular
runtime such as express
with the functions framework and then
with the user score and dependencies
everything uh in green below is managed
by google
and only the user's code is what is
provided by the user
and what we have done at google is we
have taken the second green box which is
the functions framework for each
language and runtime
and open sourced it we call this the
functions framework
for example here's the functions
framework for nodejs on cloud
functions now with this functions
framework a user can run a function
locally
with their favorite ide and here's an
example of the node.js functions
framework along with a node function
in your favorite ide and then a user can
basically step through code
write code when they're on a plane and
debug and test it
and then integrate with their team when
they land on
along with diagnostic ability language
and local development
users really care about availability and
scalability for their serverless
services
cloud functions is available in a broad
range of regions
and today we're super excited to
announce that we have added 13 new
regions
over the past year for cloud functions
making the total number of regions
19 where the product is offered with
this global availability of the service
we're super excited to provide it to our
users
in the broad range of markets in the
world along with availability
users really care about scalability for
their serverless services
and functions cloud functions is backed
by google's infrastructure which runs
uh with you know on borg and it uses a
technology called g-wiser which really
helps its scale
and here's an example of a load test
where you know a server service
for cloud functions is sent several
thousands of requests
and we see that all of the requests are
served and none of them are dropped
and the cloud functions scales
seamlessly in this test
along with availability and scalability
users really care about openness and
persuasiveness
of their you know application and
serverless service
and here's a key differentiator for
cloud functions in the space where cloud
functions
with the underlying functions framework
that runs it and the build mechanism to
build it
have all been open sourced as a result a
user can take their function
and deploy to cloud functions which is a
fully managed product they can run it
locally
in their favorite ide while they're on a
plane they can also take that function
and run it in any environment where you
can run a container
this could be cloud run which is our
serverless containers product
or any other container environment in
other clouds as well
this is a really key differentiator for
the product and now i'd like to invite
dustin on stage to provide you a demo on
functions
everywhere to walk you through this
vision
if we're a developer who's not used to
working with containers
let's see how we can use build packs to
take our existing cloud function
with its simple developer experience and
have it automatically turn into a
container
that we can run anywhere including the
powerful cloud run
all without having to understand docker
files or how to create a container
you can use build packs to turn your
source code into a containerized
application
either locally using the pack command or
in google cloud build which has support
in
alpha bill pax will look at the source
code of your application
and figure out what is the language what
is the run time and what will it take to
turn your application
into a container so in this case i'm
going to use the local pack build
command and we'll give it a destination
where we want to publish the container
we'll also let it know that it's a
google cloud function
this is the name of the function within
our file that we want to run
so if we go to my container registry and
refresh you can see here is the
container
that we just built see just now and
again containers are portable so i can
deploy to kubernetes engine
or virtual machines on compute engine
but let's deploy it on cloud run because
it's fully managed
just like cloud functions once you're
using cloud run
you have some advanced configuration
settings so you can customize how much
memory it has
you can give it two cpus and you have a
longer timeout in cloud run
you can also do concurrency so one
running instance
of your application could handle
multiple requests which might lead to
fewer cold starts and more efficient
usage
and potentially you can set the minimum
and maximum number of instances
now that is deployed you can see that
cloud run gives us a url
just like cloud functions but you can
also specify your own domain name
let's post some more temperature
readings to the app that is running on
cloud run
and if i pop over here to firestore you
can see the data coming in
click here and we can prove that is in
fact going to the cloud function
that is running on cloud run so we were
able to take our existing cloud function
with just source code and using build
packs turn it into a containerized
application
that can be run anywhere even the
powerful cloud run
thank you dustin for that amazing demo
on functions everywhere
please check out cloud functions at
cloud.google.com stroke functions
please also check out our functions
framework and build packs which are open
sourced
the github links are provided here in
addition
if any questions please feel free to
reach out to dustin
or myself that's a wrap of our session
thank you dustin and matthew for joining
me in this session
and i wish our viewers a great
confidence